مع غروب الشمس وحلول الساعه السابعه مساء
تدب الحياه في ملعب التدريب العائد لفريق
الجزيره الاماراتي فحرار في البلاد خلال
ساعات النهار لا تطاق ولا يمكن بالتالي
اجراء التدريبات الرياضيه القاسيه ومع
اننا في منتصف شهر سبتمبر وقد قابت الشمس
باشعتها الحارقه الا ان اثار الرطوبه
العاليه والحراره المرتفعه تبدو بوضوح على
اللاعبين الذين يتصبب عرقا رغم ان هم في
الدقائق الاولى من التحميه ما يعطي فكره
كافيه حول ما قد تكون عليه الحال في اشهر
الصيف التي عاده ما تستغلها الفرق
الخليجيه من اجل اقامه معسكرات في اوروبا
فخلال شهري يوليو تموز واغسطس اب تتجاوز
الحراره حاجز ال 40 درجه ليس في الامارات
فحسب وانما في كل دول الخليج بما فيها قطر
التي ستستضيف كاس العالم في عام
2022 البرازيلي الدولي ريكاردو اوليفيرا
يلعب مع نادي الجزيره منذ عام 2009 وسبق
له ان خاض مباريات في اجواء دافئه
باسبانيا وايطاليه اتذكر في موسم الاول
انني شعرت بعدم القدره على الاستمرار
وابلغت مدربي بذلك في بعض الاحيان يريد
العقل ان يستمر في اللعب ولكن الجسد يرفض
ذلك قطر قدمت خططها من اجل بناء ملاعب
توفر ظروفا مناخيه مناسبه للاعبين اثناء
المباريات في حال خوض كاس العالم صيفا
ولكن الناس الذين يحبون عاده التجول في
شوارع المدن المستضيفه للبطوله سيواجهون
مصاعب كثيره ان حاولوا فعل ذلك في قطر
بسبب الظروف
المناخيه لا اعتقد ان بالامكان تنظيم كاس
العالم في قطر صيفا هذا سيكون صعبا
الغايه لقد سبق ان جر تنظيم كاس العالم في
مناطق حاره كما حصل في المكسيك والولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ولكن درجات الحراره
اثناء تلك المباريات كانت اقل بعشر درجات
على اقل تقدير من الحراره في
الخليج